et pour ces précisions et on apprend que
21 migrants arrêtés ce matin ont été
libérés ce soir dont 4 pour se faire
soigner de la gale
alors sept ans après la fermeture du
centre de sangatte dans le pas de calais
les campements comme la jungle se sont
multipliées sur toute la côte de la
manche
les associations sont formels si le
démantèlement d'un camp donne l'illusion
de régler le problème de l'immigration
clandestine
il ne fait en réalité que le déplacer
france gêne au zoo denis guérin patrick
dur stores gagné l'angleterre à tout
prix et par n'importe quel moyen
voilà ce qui pousse chaque année des
milliers de clandestins vers calais où
en dix ans les autorités n'ont jamais su
comment faire face au phénomène en 1999
à face à l'afflux de migrants l'état
ouvre un centre géré par la croix rouge
c'est la naissance de sangatte le jour
1500 clandestins se regroupent ici où
ils peuvent se laver ou prendre un repas
chaud toutes les nuits sans relâche
ils tentent leur chance en s'entassant
dans des camions et des par les passeurs
ou en sectionnant les successions de
grillage qui empêche de pénétrer dans le
tunnel sous la manche et ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux l'an 3 ans
sangatte accueille soixante dix mille
personnes en 2002 nicolas sarkozy alors
ministre de l'intérieur décide de fermer
le camp avec l'espoir de tarir le flux
de clandestins
enfin ils se regroupent dans les bois
d'une zone industrielle
malgré les températures glaciales l'inr
les clandestins s'y entassent dans des
tentes
entre eux ironiquement il appelle cela
la jungle je ne suis pas un animal ce
sont les animaux qui vivent dans la
jungle
nous on est des humains il m'a des
animaux aujourd'hui ce type de
campements de fortune s'est multiplié
dans le nord de la france et en belgique
il y en a également un peu partout le
long des côtes de la manche jusque dans
le finistère et même à park à 40
kilomètres de calais un autre camp à ce
matin était investi par la police
pourtant cet après-midi les clandestins
sont déjà de retour et on est serein sur
un camp qui date depuis la fermeture de
sangatte
il était 10 fois démoli dit fort
construit donc les opérations sont
ridicules quimbert avant que nous
partions à remettre un irakien nous
explique qu'il souhaite traverser la
manche que coûte
ici les migrants ne sont pas près de
renoncer à leur rêve
arrivé si près du but